hello everyone and welcome to another
game between grandmaster Andrew tank and
Lila chests zero this is the second game
planed in the time format that is 15
minutes plus two seconds increment as
only two games were played in this
format in this match so I thought it'd
be nice to show this one as well as yeah
as you'll see even this is not enough
time to face an AI like a little a zero
but it's a very interesting game because
at one point
Andrew tank refuses a draw well maybe it
wouldn't be a draw but he doesn't even
want to attempt to go for a draw and
then at other point Oliva also refuses a
draw but you know for those of you who
played the London system who enjoy
playing against London system I am not
sure if I you'll find this game very
enjoyable so this game andrew has the
white pieces as in the previous one he
was black played against the Scotch he
opens with d4 we have a Knight to f6 and
the Bishop to F for preparing the London
system east 6 and III now we do have the
London system c5 and here we have Knight
to f3 and seek actors on d4 here Andrew
said if Lila want for this bv6 idea that
he had a very special thing planned with
Knight to c3 obviously this is a this is
a line he enjoys playing against the
London Eye
while playing the London against b6 I
haven't seen this line but for those of
you who follow his dreams often you
might be familiar with this but after
Knight to f3 seek after Sundy for we
have eek after son before and now Queen
to b6 and Andrew was very disgusted by
this Queen to b6 move he spent a lot of
time on this more it's a 15-minute game
and he spent about 3 minutes and this
move and as soon as the Lilla plated he
said what why does she play this no one
plays this and now you're beep one is
under attack he did have some ideas of
going Knight to c3 but he even he said
that after she captures she she was
simply crush him so basically he said he
doesn't want to play Queen to c1 but he
will play it and this is what he plays
after some three minutes of considering
we have d6 c3 Bishop to d7 and Bishop to
d7 is a very
from preparing a bush of the c6 and also
with Bishop to d7 Lila is guarding the
be 5 square which is very important
because Andrew did have some ideas of
going Knight to f3 followed by Knight to
c4
so Knight B to d2 and that's kind of the
reason if he did go for this then simply
d5 the bishop now attacks the night that
is awkwardly placed on 83 and if you
know I mean now you can go nice to b5 as
now the bishop is already guarding b5 so
instead he plays the Knight B to d2
we have Bishop to e7 a bishop to d3 and
Bishop to c6 and rucastles and now Queen
back to dat the queen is no longer
useful on b6 o Allah brings it back and
replace h3 which idea is that if this
night ever comes to h5 this Bishop has a
night retreat square on h2 so the knight
will never be able to bother this Bishop
h6 we have rook to e1 and now b5 Queen
d1 we have a six and now Queen to e2
Knight B to d7 Bishop to g3 and now
Leela finally castles nice to f1 Reema
nuvaring the Knight to Queen to b6 with
some ideas of pushing b4 and here night
the e3 93 now before wouldn't really
wouldn't really make much sense because
now we have Knight to c4 attacking the
Queen and the d6 pawn the d6 pawn is now
attacked twice by the knight and the
bishop on g3 you'd have to protect it
and then it simply lose the b4 pawn so
after 93 rook f28 by Leela rook a to D 1
and here 90 to h5 and this is the first
interesting moment of the game I mean
interesting from the perspective that a
draw for it's kind of offered and kind
of refused Bishop to h2 by Andrew and
now Eli place tonight back to f6 and
here it's it's very interesting what
would happen if Andrew went back for
Bishop to f4 would would Lila repeat
tonight to h5 now I don't know if Lila
can decide whether to accept a draw
would you offer a draw and maybe as
maybe not we'd have to ask the
developers
in any way andrew is not interested and
replaced bishop to be one so we have
Queen to be seven and now creating this
powerful battery couldn't be seven
Bishop to c6
we have brushed back to g3 and knife to
f8 and with the small knife to f8 Lilla
is not guarding the h7 square and there
is never any any real danger of this
screen coming to d3 or c2 and and
pressuring the h7 square nice to g4
offering a trade of knights and we have
knife to h5 again Lela goes for the
bishop brush up to h2 and rook a to d8
we have nice to eighth ninth to e3 a
little plays Knight back to f6 and we
have Knight to g4 once again and it's
interesting now Lila can again go for a
draw but now it's actually Lila that
refuses the draw and plays Knight
captures on g4 we have h captures on g4
and now Bishop to d5 here
Andrew was already very long time I
believe at this point he was around 1
minute and Lila was at some say 6 or 7
minutes on the clock and it's not all
that simple to find the move here for
black and Lelia plays Bishop to d5 and
it's a very very very strong move to
make especially when white is very low
on time you have to you always have to
consider before coming to c4 and well
it's not all that easy to find a move
for white either
we have Bishop back to g3 Queen to c7
and now Knight study to no longer
allowing any Bishop c4 ideas but Queen
to c6 and now Bishop to g4 offering some
exchanges a5 we have Queen to f3 and now
Bishop captures on e4 Knight captures on
d4 and d5 Knight goes back to d2 and now
sorry
and now b4 and replace c4 and here we
have Bishop to f6 attacking the d4 pawn
Bishop to g5 defending and immediately
Bishop captures
we have rook captures and Knight to g6
attacking the rook rook to e1 and now
Queen to a4 are going for the a to pawn
Queen to b3 offering a trade of Queens
and also defending the pawn queen back
to c6 and we have c5 now
we have E 5 now this as despawn advanced
now of course you want to attack the
default one to make this point week
Queen back to e3 and now Queen to c8
attacking the g4 pawn here
Andrew defended wood f3 and now we have
Queen back to c7 nice to f1 which ideas
of coming to g3 maybe to a5 but also
after this pawn captures here and not to
allow any Queen to g3 ideas so we have
pawn captures Queen captures and now
rook captures on e1 rook captures any
one and Knight to f4 here Andrew was
already I believe he was uh he was below
below 30 seconds I would say maybe maybe
even less and Leela was still above like
6 minute mark we have 9th to e3 and here
we have 9 3 6 and it was in this
position that Andrew think he didn't
resign the game but it was in this
position that his time ran out because
well ever since this move was played
there's really no no no move for white
to make black is threatening this with
the attack on the Queen end on the pawn
and there's a really no good way to save
this pawn so Andrew try Knight to e3
with the idea that if black knight moves
then he has a double attack on the d5
pawn but Leo played this just as well
and here his time ran out because here
after we move the Queen you simply lose
the c5 pawn and the pawn on d5 is
defended twice and the idea of actually
capturing it with Knight captures and of
course in black captures your Queen you
will capture the Queen and c7 this idea
loses to the very obvious Queen to d7
and you lose the night but you know yes
that's what happens when you're a very
long time and have to make a lot of
difficult decisions so yeah after this
night to e6 move his time ran out and it
in the rapid section a little just 0 1
both of the games and in case you missed
my previous video here are here is the
final score of this match Lila 140
points and Andrew won 4 points with
and out of those points as I've said in
the previous video he won one game it
was an ultra bullet game and as a lot of
you requested to see a tie okay I will
show this game as a bonus third video
today and as of tomorrow we can we can
go back to some some official
championships like the Shanker and and
the United States Championship so yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
and yeah it's very interesting I mean
even the first game and especially the
second game Andrew really put up an
excellent fight and Levi really didn't
show anything anything special and if he
were if it was a longer match who knows
who knows if Lila could even win one
game against Andrew but they did say
that if Andrew win wins one game that
they will update Lila and that she will
become even stronger so he did win one
game it's a it's a I will follow up on
their Twitter page and everything and
see if they will in fact upgrade her so
yeah that's that's basically it I would
like to thanks Steven sorry
Sarek for a contribution to my channel
or it could be Steven charge you can
never tell but nevertheless thank you
for a contribution I really appreciate
it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon with
that game were Leela blunders her Queen
thank you